la circulation de l'air cet jouerait un
rôle important dans la propagation de la
coved 19 surtout dans les résidences
pour personnes âgées et les ch et celle
des entreprises montréalaises brainbox &
à et vient de mettre sur pied un système
d'atténuation des virus aéroportée dans
les installations de ventilation et de
chauffage
on va essayer de comprendre ce que ça
veut dire avec jean simon 20 et les
chèvres la technologie cofondateur de
l'entreprise qu'est ce que ça fait mieux
vivre votre système quand ça marche
c'est assez simple c'est que l'ensemble
des édifices ont été configurés
programmées durant les dernières années
je voudrais dans les vingt dernières
années pour optimiser la consommation
énergétique tout en respectant le code
du bâtiment
donc les changements d'air combien de
fois on va venir changer l'air dans une
pièce 1 1 est conçu pour des règles
générales en bout de dix fois par et
l'apport d'air frais mais pour
évidemment c'est d'économiser c'est le
show profit de l'afrique se retrouve à
l'extérieur qu'on doit ramener la
température de la pièce où l'été faire
le contraire de dire d'admir climatisé
et on respecte les normes du bâtiment on
a fait deux pas en prendre trop nous on
a regardé cette situation là parce que
notre expertise à l'état d'économiser
l'énergie et tout l'ensemble de notre
système d'intelligence artificielle
était configuré on y re optimiser encore
plus ce système là on a regardé la
situation actuelle on s'est dit dans le
fond les recommandations actuelles
émises par les différentes autorités en
charge de déterminer les normes étaient
à l'effet qu'il fallait augmenter le
changement d'ère le plus possible et
d'apporter le plus d'air frais de
l'extérieur possible dans les bâtiments
où les gens sont alors on a dit on va
tout simplement reconfigurer notre nos
arguments d'intelligence artificielle
on leur dira le but ici ce n'est de plus
de sauver l'énergie mais d'augmenter le
plus possible l'apport d'air frais et
les changements d'air par heure dans
n'importe quel édifice qui se seraient
déployés
maintenant évidemment le coup part je
pense aux hôpitaux par exemple qui ont
des systèmes à pression négative
c'est l'idée c'est d'apporter de l'air
non vicié si vous voulez ou non
contaminé davantage c'est ça l'objectif
tout à fait dans les hôpitaux sur déjà
configuré comme ça alors un hôpital va
avoir facilement entre
20 et 30 changement d'heure à la des
râleurs tandis qu'un édifice plus
commercial avec tampa de dix changements
d'heure alors donc oui les hôpital 8
déjà optimisé pour cette évacuation de
tout pathogènes qui pourrait en
suspension dans l'air tandis que
l'ensemble des auditifs et ce ne sont
pas configurés de cette façon hélas ce
qui est intéressant c'est que vous dites
que vous offrez cette technologie
gratuitement aux propriétaires
d'immeubles comment on fait pour y avoir
accès c'est vraiment à nous contacter
l'idée ici c'était de faire une
contribution à l'effort il ya tellement
de compagnie se maquille qui font des
dons qui amène ce qu'ils peuvent pour
aider
alors on s'est dit nous qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire on est d ingénieur en
intelligence artificielle on est
spécialisée en chauffage climatisation
ventilation
alors mettons à la disposition de tous
ceux qui le désirent cette technologie
là pour qu'on puisse faire notre part
évidemment il ya des établissements qui
en auraient possiblement bien besoin est
ce que vous avez présenté votre système
au gouvernement par exemple
oui on a présenté notre solution au
gouvernement qui sont à rien de regarder
qu'est-ce qui pourrait comme elle
pourrait l'utiliser et pour les ch et
celle des je pense à certains
établissements de vie aussi où la
situation est critique évidemment est ce
que dans certains établissements
vieillissant où les infrastructures sont
désuètes dans certains cas est-ce qu'on
peut quand même introduire ce type de
technologie oui tout à fait
l'intelligence artificielle va
reconnaître les limites des systèmes
donc évidemment va tenter d'optimiser
les systèmes en place et va amener ça
dans la limite du raisonnable puisque
les systèmes peuvent peut fournir comme
étant donc c'est juste de changer la
configuration ici on vient pas changer
les systèmes et de et leur état donc ce
que je comprends c'est que c'est assez
simple à installer comment ça fonctionne
il s'agit dont vous envoie une boîte on
le fait même à travers des courriers en
utilise facetime pour guider clients
pour qui connecte lui-même la boit une
fois que la boîte est connecté au
système de contrôle de climatisation ou
de chauffage de l'édifice à distance
nous on vient de terminer la
configuration avec nos ingénieurs et on
vient s'assurer que les gens sortis ciel
est bien configuré pour amener le
maximum de valeur la santé du président
et ça prend combien temps monsieur
veines pour obtenir une
meilleure qualité de l'air à partir du
moment où s'est installée c'est une
question de jours c'est l'intelligence
artificielle a besoin de l'apprentissage
donc il faut quand même il faut
collecter de l'information au début pour
que l'apprentissage se fait mais après
quelques jours le système est
complètement fonctionnel mais comment
vous faites pour être certain olol on
parle pas d'éliminer le virus le ou les
virus ou les contaminants qui seraient
présents comment comment vous faites
pour savoir pour mesurer l'amélioration
de la qualité de l'air c'est à dire que
puis c'est une très bonne question que
vous posez on ne saura pas jusque dans
quelle mesure on va éliminer
complètement ou pas des pathogènes qui
serait ou des quantités bios qui serait
en suspension dans l'air se construit
c'est qu'on va venir augmenter si dans
un édifice y avait quatre changements
d'air par an et nous on l'amène à 16,7
changement d'ère par an dans tous les
cas on vient améliorer la qualité de
l'air à l'intérieur de cet édifice
vous en avez installé beaucoup jusqu'à
maintenant monsieur veine on commence à
installer où il ya plusieurs clients
étonnamment on reçoit même des demandes
de vancouver on était surpris par cet
engouement la quitte à l'extérieur du
québec
et là on commence à avoir des demandes
oui au québec donc c'est un nouveau
chapitre si vous voulez vous avez un peu
par la force des choses découvert cette
nouvelle capacité pour votre entreprise
à ou des portes
bah écoute et une contribution de voir
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire avec
l'exigence artificielle on sait on sait
retourner très rapidement la sur indices
ou comme on dit au québec pour adapter
nos algorithmes leur dire non maintenant
on veut plus sauvé d'énergie on veut on
veut maximiser la quantité d'air frais
et puis le changement d'apparence et
voilà on en utilise les mêmes regrette
qu'on a reconfiguré avec un objectif
différent
oui absolument merci monsieur ben ça m'a
fait plaisir
bonsoir enfin